but don't even do the voice I'm in such
a bad mood now don't even do the [ __ ]
voice I have a voice Oh Bobby that's
great quick hey everybody I'm a 27 year
old girl who has a crush on a guy I'm
Asian and he is white I'm pretty
reluctant to date white guys in general
and I would never date a guy with yellow
fever I'm pretty sure he's not that but
he has a close-knit group of friends and
what I would say 75% of them are in a
white guy
asian girl couple is that weird that
this is the one thing that puts me off
should I go for it anyway or should I
just wait this crush out I think that
listen the future is this a hundred
years from now if the androids and the
robots don't kill us Americans are gonna
look Brown we're all gonna look the same
we need to we need to crossbreed as
quickly as we can oh you know you got a
date look at you like that I mean you're
gonna just you're gonna die alone all
right you're gonna die alone and I'm
sorry for it let's erase that part okay
but I just think this lady right here
Gator white dude I'm all for it now I
used to be opposed to it but if you're
an Asian guy to date white chicks date a
brown person date a black person date
let's crossbreed Twila your thoughts on
crossbreeding mm-hmm I think that she's
she sounds like somebody who's probably
dated the whole rainbow of men which I
applaud you for I think you should try
every single flavor on the menu but it
sounds like she's put off by the a by
the idea not of his whiteness but by the
fact that all of his other white friends
are with majority of them are with Asian
women so she maybe feels like he could
potentially have yellow fever fever and
strictly only be attracted to Asian
women so that's what Bobby has a problem
with I think generally when you don't
like when you just are very specific to
one thing but if he's a good guy and the
only thing that's putting me off is his
whiteness and his friends I I wouldn't
let that deter you from giving him a
chance Bobby thank you for being an
inspiration rereading it from one form
add it to another things every you been
through and overcome makes me want to be
a better person
you rock you taught me that it's okay to
be weird and to embrace it that's all
I'm saying
shows for Bobby cloud we're not doing a
second question one other one no taken I
mean I you know what you know I'll be
real with you man I thought it was a
good podcast and at the end I petered
out because I got destroyed by you with
your movie [ __ ] and you know what and
because I you put a mirror in my face
and I got to look at me
the slept King very handsome on point
but still I saw my own flaws and and I
am going to catch up yeah I'm gonna
catch up every time I can I have this
sticker again it's a detail it's not
just a sticker so I put on my car yep I
could cool